PKI can be confusing.
For our purposes, you need to
master three concepts, public and
private keys, the difference between the
message, the sensitive information and
the digital signature derived
from it and attached to it.
And the function of
two key organizations.
The first organization confirms
the identity of the people or
entities involved in
the exchange of information.
This is the Registration Authority,
or RA.
Functionally separate,
although one organization could
do both is actually signing and
issuing additional certificates
that are bound to that identity.
This is the Certificate Authority,
or CA.